now tissues like this that we just
discussed that I think are invigorating
Republicans ahead of the midterms
um and they might need it looks this
brand new Trafalgar poll is presenting
some warning signs for the GOP some say
because 56 percent of Voters say
Republicans haven't made a strong enough
case for support in the November
midterms and among Independents it's 57
but joining me now is a man who will
likely be the speaker of the house
should Republicans win this November
House minority leader Kevin McCarthy
he's unveiling the gop's four-part
commitment to America on September 23rd
23rd it is yes all right so that
Trafalgar poll people want to hear more
than Biden Bad Country going down the
tubes what are they going to hear in
keeping in mind what we just talked
about with these schools exactly the
people want to know what you're for we
know what the Democrats have have done
to US inflation crime going into our
schools a government that's not held
accountable on the borders is not secure
so what we'll do on the 23rd and where
how we got here for the last year and a
half all of our members have been
working in task forces to build the
policy see so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to make a
economy that is strong so that means
going after inflation stopping inflation
how are you going to do it that's that's
a nice headline but how you're going to
that's great well the first thing you
got to do you've got to stop the runaway
spinning that caused it you watch that
two defund defund organizations agents
you're going to defund the 87 000 IRS
agents you're going to make America
energy independent to start with go back
to the policies that worked two and a
half years ago exactly and we want to
restore America where they're stronger
we want to bring everyone together again
and then the other thing we're going to
do we want a community that's safe we're
going to not defund the police we're
going to add 200 000 new police officers
but the other thing that's happening
here is these prosecutors that won't
uphold the law we're going to take a
page out of Reagan where when he raised
the age to 21 we put Supply billions of
dollars in cop grants we're going to put
a score to every prosecutor in the
nation give a transparency of what
they're upholding or not and they've got
to read us reach a score if they want to
have the cop grants I think their
policies will change just as we were
able isn't it time to defund uh and push
to defund large parts of the federal
government that are actually working
against the interests of the American
people the EPA the doj if it's turning
parents who care about that curriculum
that you just listened to curricula all
across the country the education
department I used to work there during
Reagan believe and I'm really dating
myself the education department must be
defunded in large part Reagan wanted to
get rid of it what happened to that we
should even have an education department
at this point you're exactly where we're
going the other thing you want to build
a future based upon freedom and the one
thing we learned in Virginia so we have
a parent's Bill of Rights so what we're
finding is someone has to do research
and get lucky to find out what these is
happening in these kids schools that
should not be the challenge every parent
should be sent what's ever being taught
in their kids school they don't have to
go to a website to see it they should be
able to have sent to them and they know
it what we're also going to do is hold
this government accountable why did the
doj go after parents when they started
going to school board meetings to stop
critical race Theory because they could
the Unions would not have it we're going
to oversee the doj go after why did this
even start from well you go back to
remain in Mexico policy policy carrying
our border remain in Mexico no more
Catch and Release what's happening at
the border and I want to tell you a
story that happened in my hometown just
last week a 13 year old brought 150
pills of fentanyl disguised as something
else a counselor fan this is in junior
high a counselor finds it
as the police officer going there they
have to call paramedic because the
counselor didn't take a pill but he
started to OD because what absorbing 300
kids a day are being poisoned and China
is launching a drug war on the United
States this is a drug war that's being
launched through Mexico waged by China
to kill a hundred thousand Americans
I'll tell you what we're going to do
next but this is like an airplane full
commercial crashing every day why
wouldn't this be a crisis if a plane
crashed every day in America we'd do
something are we bringing Supply chains
home from China China decoupling you
know I've been talking about it for 20
years that's exactly around on this I
think many times we're bringing the
supply chain back but let me tell you
something else if I'm fortunate enough
to be speaker I'm going to create a
China committee we are going to look at
committee what's that going to do just
bring the supply chains on no we're
going to bring the supply chain but you
have to look at every single industry
that they have a corner they control 90
percent of all the critical minerals but
they also control 95 of all the critical
mineral processing why are we being so
beholden to China why don't we bring
that back to us should they be able to
buy the farmland in the United States
military base that's part of what the
committee will do um I don't you know
when I hear committee my head blows off
but I I get what you're saying that's
how you pass legislation oh God the
details are important Congressman all
right Nancy Pelosi discussed Democrats
prospects today Congressman I want you
to watch what she said
how many times have I told you over the
past year and a half plus that the
Democrats would hold the house despite
some of the so-called conventional
so-called wisdom in Washington D.C we
always believed we will win so we always
prepared for it
she had those bills ready to go she was
ready when she took power and get took
that gavel you know what she said last
last cycle too that there go pick up
seats all the pollsters said we'd lose
15 was the first time since 1994. not
run one Republican incumbent loss so we
beat 15 Democrats we elected the most
Republican women at any time in the
history we are going to win the majority
but it's not good it's not for the sake
of the Republican party it's for
restoring America we have a plan for a
new direction we
saw what worked we had real median
income Rising under Trump don't you miss
the days when the market was high and
inflation and gas prices were low it's
the opposite it's exactly what they have
done they opened our border they brought
inflation with runaway spending you
watch what they've done to our schools
there's no one being held accountable
you've got looking to OPEC to solve our
problems instead of America being energy
independent right here are you going to
take this this is going to be a tour
around the country what we're going to
do we're going to ask everybody join
with us we're going to have a commitment
Across America the 23rd will roll it out
but all the way through between now and
the lecture we want everybody in America
to make a decision which direction do
they want to go with what the Democrats
have done but a clear path for our plan
to change the direction no State Left
Behind no State Left Behind no District
Left Behind got to take back New England
we're going to win in Rhode Island Alan
Fong we're going to win in Oregon we're
going to win in Arizona you look at Juan
Cisco money we're going to win in Texas
in the most Hispanic parts of the
country look at Myra Flores we're taking
all your state back in California we're
going to win in California all right
with no State left behind we got to take
them all back Congressman thank you it's
great to see you thanks for coming to
the studio hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else